what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water we have another interview
from Sundance 2023 it's for a
documentary that I absolutely adored
It's Only Life After All
congratulations congratulations
Alexander I'm going to start with you of
course I was reading a little bit about
how the original plan was to film the
documentary while on tour with them and
then that had to change so what's the
biggest difference between how you
envision the film turning out with that
original plan versus where you landed
with it well I mean definitely had a lot
of
you know big different plans for this
film before covid but you know
everything kind of worked out in the way
it was supposed to in the end
um and and beginning of film I never
know exactly what it's going to be I
only know like big themes or things I
want to listen to or pay attention to
and the interviews really that we did in
2020 really dictated so much of this
story and I don't we didn't actually
know that Amy had a massive Archive of
footage in her basement
um until like eight months into shooting
she was like hey you should come in and
check this out I was like what is
happening and this and so I didn't
really know yet and so that really was
just a whole nother element
um you know it was that footage plus
Sony footage and other things that we
came across ended up being over a
thousand hours of footage so I mean that
my last films were verite films and so
this was my first archive film and so
that made a yeah that was a big
difference yeah the first and last
archive film but uh definitely like the
best one and yeah
that footage yourself yeah yeah yeah
totally agree so you just you brought up
the fact that some of your past films
are more in the verite style and this is
more of an archival film is there
anything about making a film that way
that when you go back to the verite
style might influence your work in that
particular form as well wow that's
amazing question
um yeah hopefully it's not all downhill
from here
um man I hope so I mean I learned a lot
about I mean every film I make I learn
so much about storytelling and
um my my values are so determined and
um in the films themselves uh I think
more than the style of editing like just
learning so much from Amy and Emily as
people and how they prioritize community
and activism and service and
self-acceptance it's just you know that
inherently changes so much about me as a
person and therefore my art so yeah it
made a massive difference in my life I'm
a completely different person now so now
Amy and Emily when you actually joke
about this in the movie the idea that
like you didn't know what the story was
going to be and that's Alexandra's job
going in ultimately in the end when you
view the finished film what is the most
surprising thing about the story you did
wind up telling
I think I was pretty amazed at the
nuances that she pulled out of all that
footage and realized that she had
actually probably looked at every single
minute of all the footage because the
things that she pulled out were very uh
kind of under the radar not the same old
tropes and the same old things and then
they're strung together in a way that's
to me
it's just very Artful and I I guess I
just
I don't know I mean I didn't think you
could make a documentary about us that
had that kind of flow and Arc and nuance
and it's just the way we've gotten
talked about most of the time has been
so tropey
you know not all the time let's just say
half of half of it so it's so nice to
have something that's like art and
nuanced and tender but also angsty and
has everything all the dimension in it
and it's real it's just really real and
authentic you know it may be a little
bit maybe a little bit Punk okay yes a
little bit Punk yeah
thank you
is there anything that made it into the
final film whether it's like a specific
experience you went through or maybe
thematically that you were surprised
emerged over the course of the
filmmaking process well it was kind of
fun to revisit some of those interviews
that I'd forgot completely forgotten
about we were just so little babies you
know and that was fun to see that but
like even thing I know that Alexander
was meticulous about everything that she
chose and I know that she made changes
and so everything was very very
purposefully Chosen and so there's a
scene where a scene is that what you
call it where all these people have gone
she's at a concert and these people who
are attending the concert are talking
about what our music has meant to them
and that feels weird to say but that's
what happened and there's just this
ugly old chair that's right there like
in the middle of an outside thing in the
juxtaposition of that chair and then
they come and they sit in the chair a
singular person mostly and then talk
about the music and I found on that
particularly poignant because they were
saying things they were being very
vulnerable about their own lives and the
struggles they'd been through and how
they connected to the music and there's
just something about that that chair the
vulnerability uh it was very striking to
me
um so the the film hit me in ways that
that I wasn't expecting and I think I'm
still processing it many follow-ups that
I hope I remember but uh Alexandria
bringing up how meticulous you were with
everything you chose going into the edit
is there any particular thing that you
were certain you were going to use and
highlight but over the course of the
editing process it wound up being
rightfully deprioritized in order to
come out with the film you wound up with
well as a fan I was like oh man I do I
just get to pick my favorite songs like
how is this gonna work and I had no idea
how to incorporate music into the film
you know this is
um lyric heavy songs and so it's hard to
have you know dialogue with lyrics and
so trying to figure out how what songs
come through you know 40 Years of songs
like that's a lot to pick from
and also incredible so it ended up just
being the story kind of dictated what
songs came through but um yeah I had no
idea how that was gonna go and it was
really interesting at the end of the day
what ended up being in the film yeah
going back now to what you were saying
about seeing you know people sit in that
chair and and basically just like spill
their hearts about how much your work
has meant to them you are so incredibly
humble in general and we see that a lot
in the movie where I feel that you
downplay the massive influence you've
had on on so many people out there you
know you said you're still processing
but now having seen the finished film
like is it setting in more than ever can
you guys fully embrace the fact that
like you've changed countless lives with
your work
this is good
you ask amazing questions yeah I I the
way I feel about it is that
it's it's very I I don't feel ownership
of that which happens you know there's a
lot of mystery to it there's a ton of
community there's all the people who
came before us the songwriters the
activists
um there's our community of people who
listen to our music and so it's just
impossible to to have ownership of that
because there's it's it's
it's complex you know and I know what it
feels like to tap into music that I need
at a critical moment in my life that
feeds me emotionally or intellectually
or whatever the case may be so I know
that music is at the center of my very
being and so I understand that but to
try to feel the impact of of you know
affecting people's lives in that way
just because of us I just can't do it
it's just yeah I just can't
I can understand not being able to fully
embrace it but it's there like it's
factual it is the truth like but this is
what happens it's like an exchange of
energy in a way you know because it's
like when we started we were so young
and there were a lot of ways that we
just we didn't understand our own
sexuality or gender or or families or
what or politics or our activism and so
a lot of the people that listen to us
also were doing good work and we were
exchanging ideas too so there's a lot of
this thing that almost feels like the a
brew of like stuff that we've mixed
together and then we're all drinking
from that and and it's you know
emboldening us and giving us strength
and stuff in a way you know so we can
embrace it but it's it's a it's we're
embracing the mystery of it you know and
the power of musical lineage and because
you know we come from listening to the
roaches and Farren and you know the
Carter family you know what I mean it's
like
think about it it's all so much DNA just
going along in the musical notes and we
just get to be part of it putting you
feel grateful for it for sure yeah
you know and there's the Confluence of
that then I do feel grateful that we
were we were the ones who were able to
meet you at the intersection at that
point
putting a little bit of a movie spin on
that idea in honor of the Sundance Film
Festival
do each of you have maybe a movie that
you fell in love with that I don't know
impacted your own life or stuck with you
the way that your music has stuck with
so many people out there
so many there's like a million so many
I mean I can start to name a few oh I'm
here for it well this is in the film
that I talk about personal best and what
that felt like to be a terrified person
discovering her sexuality and seeing
that but you know films like Cinema de
Paradiso
um and I used to watch a lot of the the
foreign films that came through the
movie theaters uh call me by your name
was very affecting uh Black Panther was
completely affecting
um Moonlight very affecting
um God there's just so many
so those are just the first that come to
mind I'll regret the ones I forget later
I like that list though do you want to
add to the list Amy
I I my brain is like okay
uh
you know 400 blows like french fries
truffaut was really important to me when
I was younger and Peter Greenway was
really important
um daughters of the Dust is one of my
favorite movies of all time and I still
check back in with that a lot it really
impacted me and changed my perspective
and really made me dig deeper into
you know just anti-racism work and
history and stuff like that I'll throw a
similar question your way now Alexandria
so it is very special when two artists
can find each other and realize that
they are the right collaborators so who
would you say is your filmmaking Amy and
Emily someone you know you can always
turn to when you need that support when
doing the difficult thing of making a
movie
like that like that I'm working with
right now right now or in the past
anyone you can lean on oh definitely
Brock Williams
100 Brock Williams
um Brock is like my brother my family
member is gonna make me cry I'm talking
about it don't look at me bro
um he has always been there for me he's
saved two of my films like been able to
make these films even come to Sundance
at all
um I'm sure we wouldn't have gotten the
film ready in time without him but he's
everything from my you know massive best
friend emotional support to a Powerhouse
producer to the guy that opened my
orange yesterday because I couldn't get
my fingernails in it
um so it's just yeah and and just an
amazing creative collaborative
collaborator he like trusts me he
respects my work and
um I trust him I respect his opinion and
I don't think you could ask for anything
more than that so it makes me so happy
bringing up the idea of the challenge of
getting movies made I remember reading
about I know you you wanted to tell this
story in a way that doesn't align with
the traditional music biopic and and
that meant you had to make it
independently which made me assume you
had had some of those bigger meetings
where maybe you could get more financing
to make a movie like this and that's a
very scary situation to be in to know
that in order to stay true to the vision
that is in your mind you need to pass on
something like that so can you walk us
through that thought process a little
well I think it's a very enticing thing
to just do the formula of a music biopic
that you know it's so prevalent in the
industry and and there's amazing films
that follow that form formula but um you
know Amy and Emily did not follow any
formulas in their career they're not
typical and um they're extraordinary in
so many ways and I felt the film needed
to reflect that and also a lot of the
reasons that you know you have a lot of
other musicians talking about how
important another musician was in these
biopixes because you need to kind of
fill in the gaps and say the things with
other interviews because maybe those
people aren't saying their faults or
aren't saying how something felt at the
time but Amy and Emily were so
forthcoming and I knew that they were
going to be because that's how we were
in conversation all the time that I knew
they could be the narrators of Their Own
Story and I felt that that was going to
be the most powerful thing I didn't need
any other famous musician to come in and
tell us how important they were
um or their lessons or you know and and
at the end of the day the interview is
you know the interview is looking
straight at the camera because I wanted
this to feel like a conversation it's a
conversation with me in the interview
but it feels like a conversation with
the audience and and so the film
reflects who they are I hope it reflects
their music and just Justice to their
legacy as musicians and activists for
what it's worth from my perspective it
does I feel like this is the worst
question to ask at a film festival but
given what a special experience you had
and that it it veers away from your
traditional documentary filmmaking style
what is something you're walking away
from with this movie that might
influence the films that you make going
forward now
I mean definitely this film has
influenced me in so many ways I mean
it's helped me with my own queer
acceptance It's helped me understand my
relationship with activism in a whole
new way
um a lot of the films I've made have
been about very difficult topics and
really I was going into this film pretty
pretty disheartened but just really
feeling reinvigorated now about
Grassroots activism and just a whole new
lease on that and
especially when it comes to values
around Community this film really
changed my life and I think going into
filmmaking now like I want to make films
with Brock I want to make films with my
close friends and collaborators and
that's the priority from here on out and
just
um yeah making films and community and
doing it from those core values
you two both have a movie coming up too
glitter and doom your first your first
experience composing for a feature film
what has that been like and what would
you say is I guess the biggest learning
curve you went on making music in that
particular format well actually it's
interesting because they took they use
songs that already existed and they made
mashups of them
Super Creative like we didn't do that
um so it was all them
and we wrote as we're working on a song
for the end credits original song and
that's been a challenge
um because we've never I've never
written for a specific like movie so
that's that's interesting to do we're
not done yet but it's almost done
um yeah they made mashups of things and
then produced them and the characters
sing them in the film and it's like the
story of two men glitter and doom are
really they're very young actually when
they meet and they it's like their love
affair and struggle with their own lives
and what they go through in their
community and everything through the
lens of like a lot of our songs and
stuff but it's really interesting
mashups so it's not just like Indigo
Girl songs it's like a whole new
creation of their own it's very um I
don't know it's kind of like cross
between
Cirque du Soleil Moulin Rouge
songs yeah
we read the script and we really loved
the script yeah you know and so we said
you know pick the songs and
we'll see as though I wasn't interested
in that enough that description I'm just
I like I don't quite know it's a picture
but I also get a sense of it and it just
it sounds like it's going to be right up
my alley as as was this documentary I I
love the I want to make sure I get this
on camera I love the way you approached
making it because I think it does their
work Justice and a lot of Indigo Girls
fans out there will feel very seen by
your documentary but also The Narrative
Approach you took makes it Universal
we'll introduce people to not only your
music but also the beliefs that you
stand by and I can't ask for anything
else from a documentary like this so
from the bottom of my heart
congratulations
I used to go on camera that you're
amazing yeah you're really good at the
Cow we've done a lot of interviews
finger snaps out in the audience well
now that turned my brain and heart into
mush and I don't know if I can do an
outro seriously thank you for saying
that everyone out there please do not
miss miss this movie and stay tuned
we'll have more interviews from Sundance
2023 for you real soon